the supreme court has suddenly become
the dominant election issue in the
united states
donald trump says he's going to move
forward with filling a vacancy this week
democratic challenger joe biden says
with early voting already underway
that's simply wrong the people of this
nation are choosing their future
right now as they vote to jam this
nomination through the senate
it's just an exercise in raw political
power
and i don't believe the people of this
nation will stand for it
president trump told a rally in south
carolina on saturday he's sending his
nomination for consideration
to the senate this week it will be a
woman
a very talented very brilliant woman
we haven't chosen yet but we have
numerous women on the list
there are thought to be two leading
candidates amy coney barrett is an
appeals court judge a favorite of
conservatives
and has been considered for earlier
vacancies and there's barbara lagua
a latin woman from florida which would
be the more political choice
but the white house might not be able to
push through any nomination before the
election
in the last 45 years the process has
taken on average
68 days the election is just over 40
days away
and there's questions about the
president even making a nomination
before november the 3rd
texas republican senator ted cruz is in
no doubt
in order for a supreme court nomination
to go forward you have to have the
president
and the senate in this instance the
american people voted they elected
donald trump
but there's potential for the court to
become the center of a constitutional
crisis
if republicans can't push through a
nomination before the election
they may try to do it before the
inauguration on january the 20th
but if joe biden wins that election that
could cause problems
the democratic leader of the house says
they have ways to delay a nomination
we have our options we have arrows in
our quiver
that i'm not about to discuss right now
but the fact is
we have a big challenge in our country
republicans see the vacancy as an
opportunity to change the face of the
supreme court
securing a conservative majority for
years to come
and they also believe it could galvanize
support around donald trump
both now and on election day and if
people are talking about this
they're not talking about the u.s
reaction to covet about unemployment or
about health care
all big issues before the death of a
supreme court justice
alan fisher al jazeera washington